There are so many stories of legendary creatures,
cryptids and strange monsters from all around
the world.
I’ve always wanted to start a series devoted
to individual countries so welcome to episode
one, the strange creatures of Sweden.
Many of the creatures that appear today will
also be very common in other Scandinavian
countries so you can see today's episode as
a Scandinavian special.
Before we go any further a quick word from
today's awesome sponsor HelloFresh.
Nothing really beats a home cooked meal but
deciding what to eat, buying the ingredients,
preparing and cooking the meal for most people
with a busy schedule can be difficult to do
several times a week.
With HelloFresh you can have a meal kit that
includes fresh ingredients and cooking instructions
sent directly to your door.
Simply follow the instructions provided and
you have access to all sorts of tasty meals
within 30 minutes, less time than you’d
spend at the grocery store.
Each week there are new recipes to choose
from with Low carb, Low fat and vegetarian
options.
The meal kits are sent in almost entirely
recyclable packaging so you can even reduce
your carbon footprint.
I’ve been trying HelloFresh for a few weeks
now and I’ve been extremely happy with what
I’ve received and the amount of time I’ve
been able to save.
Some of my favourite meals so far were the
Teriyaki chicken and rice, the honey roasted
duck with mash potatoes and the spicy creamy
cajun pasta.
You may be surprised to know that I’m no
Gordan Ramsey but these meals look and taste
great, you also don’t have to be a Michelin
star chef to make them.
So if you’d like to try HelloFresh for yourself,
you can visit HelloFresh.com and use code
Mythology14 to receive 14 free meals as well
as free shipping.
Give it a try and let me know which meals
were your favourite.
We begin with the not so pleasant Draugr,
and no these are not white walkers from game
of thrones if anyone was wondering.
The Draugr are animated corpses or revenants
that can be found in burial mounds guarding
treasure.
Step into the wrong tomb or try and steal
something shiny and you might just wake an
angry Draugr or two.
In Swedish they are simply referred to as
Draug which refers to someone pale and dimwitted
who drags himself along.
Given that description and the idea of animated
corpses comparing a Draug to a zombie is fairly
reasonable, they are also described as corporeal
ghosts and vampires.
The zombie comparison can be made as it’s
said you can tell when a Draugr near as the
smell of decay is unbearable, their appearance
is grotesque and necrotic.
At times they can be gaunt with broken and
exposed bones.
Towards the end of the 19th century they were
also considered a type of vampire.
Not because of the need to feed off others
in order to sustain themselves but because
their attacks could turn their victims into
their own kind.
There are brief mentions of ‘outbreaks and
epidemics in the old sagas.
As Well as superhuman strength, they could
shapeshift, control the weather and even invade
one's dream leaving behind a cursed object
ensuring the victim's bad fortune and even
death.
All of this makes being hunted by a Draugr
something you’d rather avoid.
The Skogsraet in Swedish or the Hulder in
other parts of Scandinavia is a type of forest
nymph.
Often referred to as the mistress of the forest
this entity is known for its seductive but
also deadly nature.
This mistress takes the form of a petite beautiful
woman with a kind and friendly demeanor.
From the front they appear perfectly normal,
but from the behind they have a large hollow
Chasm in their back as well as a tail.
Those unfortunate enough to interact with
these forest nymphs are never the same.
Many are simply never seen again and the ones
who do return are said to be a shell of themselves,
an introvert or hermit.
Those who lay with the Skogsraet are said
to leave behind their souls for her keeping.
One of the more disturbing set of creatures
on today's list are the Myling, these are
reanimated corpses or spirits of children
who had passed away.
They are forced to roam the earth until the
dying wish has been fulfilled, normally that
means the desire for a proper burial.
These spirits can range from young children
to newborns and even unborn children which
makes this legend even more disturbing.
The Myling exists when a mother kills an unwanted
child and hides her crime, they can be heard
at night singing their horrifying song revealing
their mothers crime.
With many of these murders happening shortly
after birth these children were never baptised
or given a proper burial thus according to
the church they could never rest.
The way to appease them is by giving them
a name, finding their corpse and burying them
in holy soil.
Because of the violent nature of their deaths
the Myling were feared and considered vengeful
spirits, if you were chosen by a Myling to
help them find their body and bury them you
had no real choice, failing to do so would
result in your own death.
The Nacken were water spirits that lured children
and women down lakes and rivers with enchanting
songs played on the violin.
Often they appeared as a man with a violin
but it’s believed they had no true shape
or form.
They could shapeshift into boxes of treasure
floating on the water's surface, a beautiful
woman or even an animal.
A common form was a horse which is why they
may also be referred to as brook horse or
river horse.
The most common form the Nacken spirit takes
in Sweden is a man playing a musical instrument
who also happens naked sometimes.
Not all Nacken were malevolent as there are
stories of them living on land and integrating
into society for short periods of time before
eventually returning to the water.
There are also tales of Nacken teaching others
how to play the violin or fiddle but some
are driven completely insane by the music.
The evil Nacken would target unbaptised children
and pregnant women with their songs but they
also drowned young men too so I guess nobody
was really safe.
The song played is so enchanting that you
forget where you are and begin walking towards
the music, before you know it you're in the
water about to drown yourself.
Similar to creatures such as the Grindylow
or the Kelpie, these tales were likely created
to keep children away from dangerous lakes
and rivers.
The mare or mara is an entity that has appeared
throughout Europe under many different names.
It is a spirit that rides on your chest while
you sleep and brings nightmares, a sleep paralysis
monster.
The Mara would ride horses during the night
leaving owners confused as to why they were
so tired and sweaty in the morning.
Once the horses were exhausted they would
find sleeping men entangle them with their
hair and begin to invade their dreams until
they became nightmares.
As well as women they could also take the
form of any animal they desire making them
very difficult to identify.
For our next sets of creatures I will now
pass you over to today's guest, Artist and
Swedish native Mando who can share some of
her
experiences
and stories.
A  huge thanks to Mando for the artwork in this
video and especially for sharing her own stories
and experiences.
If you’d like to see more she does have
her own channel called Heart full of forest
which focuses on art, nature, culture and
minimal living.
I’ll leave a link to one of Mando’s videos
for you to check out.
I hope you’ve enjoyed this episode.
If you’d like this series to continue then
let me know which country you’d like to
see next.